so donald trump did something in public
yesterday leaving the white house
for his first public appearance since
the riotous
insurrection last week donald trump was
heading out from the white house
on route to the u.s mexico border in
texas to
tell predictable lies about the wall
that was never built
and that mexico did not pay for let's
get right into it donald trump
attempting to
rewrite history blaming other people
doing everything
we would expect at this point from this
deranged man
this was on his way out to texas
[Music]
so we're going to texas we're going to
the southern border
as you know we've completed the wall
they may want to expand it
we have the expansion underway it's been
tremendously successful far beyond what
anyone thought
we're stopping in large numbers the
drugs coming into the country for many
many years and decades
we completed the wall and they may want
to expand it
hold on a second that doesn't make sense
the promise was by the end of trump's
first term which is seven days from now
a wall across the entire u.s mexico
border
if you did that how would you expand it
would you go
into the water it doesn't really make
sense
and just lie after lie after
uncontrollable
and easily disprovable lie let's
continue
as far as this is concerned we want no
violence
never violence we want absolutely no
violence and
on the impeachment it's really a
continuation of the greatest witch hunt
in the history of politics
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous
this impeachment is causing tremendous
anger
and you're doing it and it's really a
terrible thing that they're doing
now of course at this point trump saying
never violence
is silly it's saying you work
uh only with fire extinguishers not
matches
after you've already set fire to a house
and it has burned down and then you say
i'm a fire extinguisher guy at this
point forward of course i'm a fire
extinguisher guy
and again they want to put the
impeachment on democrats democrats are
divisive for considering impeachment
trump did the thing that is impeachable
and as usual
the party of personal responsibility
taking no personal responsibility
whatsoever
never i mean donald trump is going to
leave office never
having taken responsibility for any of
his failures
and he just continues attacking
democrats
for nancy pelosi and chuck schumer to
continue on this path
i think it's causing tremendous danger
to our country
and it's causing tremendous anger i want
no violence thank you very much
once again impeachment causing anger
recent poll most people want trump
removed period
we talked about that earlier this week
the anger is over what donald trump did
and his supporters went into last
wednesday already angry
thanks to two months of lies told to
them by donald trump
and rudy giuliani and kaylee mcinanny
and on and on
lies telling them joe biden stole this
election joe biden didn't really win
that's why they were angry and now to
say
democrats are causing anger give me a
break guys it's not even
uh it it's too ridiculous to even pass
the sniff test
and then that so that was trump on his
way out once trump landed in texas
again we heard from donald trump talking
to press there this time going after big
tech take a listen for our country
they're dividing and divisive
and they're showing something that i've
been predicting for a long time
i've been predicting it for a long time
and people didn't act on it
but i think big tech has made a terrible
mistake and very very bad for our
country
and that's leading others to do the same
thing
and it causes a lot of problems and a
lot of danger
so so far the people to blame
right now are democrats media
big tech still nothing from trump on the
riotous insurrection
he incited last week in terms of taking
any responsibility when in reality
that's where the primary
bulk of the responsibility is and once
again everybody but trump is to blame
you you might also notice that trump
glitches at the end of this next clip on
the word violence if you're watching
you'll
you'll again see that spasm-like thing
that we've seen throughout his
presidency we
still don't really know much about that
uh big mistake they shouldn't be doing
it
but uh there's always a counter move
when they do that i've never seen such
anger
as i see right now and that's a terrible
thing terrible thing
and you have to always avoid violence
and we have
we have tremendous support we have
support
probably like nobody's ever seen before
always
have to avoid violence and then finally
donald trump asked about the capital
directly and the speech that he gave um
which said we're going to go down to the
capitol and here is donald trump's
answer
what is your capitol what is role
personal response so if you read my
speech and
many people have done it and i've seen
it both in the papers and
in the media on television it's been
analyzed and
people thought that what i said was
totally appropriate
and if you look at what other people
have said politicians at a high level
about the riots during the summer the
horrible riots in portland and seattle
and various other
other places that was a real problem
what they said
but they've analyzed my speech and my
words and my final paragraph
my final sentence and everybody to the
key thought it was totally appropriate
okay thank you so the speech he refers
to
is the one where he said half an hour
before the riot
let's walk down pennsylvania uh avenue
and go to the capitol
and we're going to fight and we'll never
give up and on and on and on that's the
speech he says was totally appropriate
um so effectively trump trying to
rewrite history
taking no responsibility for the riot he
caused
while blaming democrats and big tech for
causing the danger
that speed that's not a speech those
statements
are extraordinarily dangerous and trump
of course used the word
fight or fighting nearly two dozen times
during that speech that he says was fine
and he said at 12 30. let's go to the
capitol uh
45 minutes later the riotous
insurrection was starting now in the
meantime as i told you
yesterday the risk of even more violence
is huge
and so even these aside from it being
obviously dishonest and completely
ridiculous for the president to try to
rewrite history in this way
we're also not past the point of danger
according to an fbi bulletin
we talked about this yesterday armed
protests like the january
6th protest are quote being planned at
all 50 state capitals
starting saturday uh through at least
january 20th and um
these these are tragic times and we are
almost done with trump
we're seven days away but there is the
real risk of more violence
over the next week and that's something
we all need to be paying attention to
if one of your goals for the new year is
to cut back on carbs and
sugar check out one of our sponsors monk
pack
monk pack keto granola bars fill you up
and taste like your favorite sweet
snacks
but they just have one gram of sugar
just two grams of net carbs at only 140
calories they have a soft
chewy texture and they come in delicious
flavors like coconut cocoa chip
peanut butter and maple pecan
or pecan or pecan it's all of the above
actually
uh they're perfect for a quick breakfast
a snack between zoom calls
or a late night treat not only are they
keto friendly they're gluten-free
grain-free plant-based no soy trans fats
or sugar alcohols no artificial colors
and monk pack is so confident in their
keto snacks
that they back them with a hundred
percent money back guarantee
try it for yourself and you'll see how
delicious these are
you'll get twenty percent off when you
go to monkpack.com and use coupon code
pacman the link is underneath this video